[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je gardais dans l'histoire du Parlement
a décidé que on avait assez de la
période de questions puis il est parti
on a on a arrêté la session pour une
trentaine de minutes ça me tente
vraiment aujourd'hui le premier ministre
recommence du début s'il vous plaît
après avoir ignoré la motion adoptée par
la Chambre des communes qui réclament le
départ de David Johnston et la tenue du
enquête publique sur la gérance
étrangère le gouvernement Trudeau
souhaite maintenant tourner la page et
se concentrer sur ses priorités
législatives une dizaine de projets de
loi doivent être adoptés avant la pause
estivale dont le budget et le programme
national de garderie elle se réaliste je
pose la question un rendu Boissonneau
ministre du Tourisme associé au finances
merci d'être avec nous monsieur
Boissonneau
commençons par le ton en chambre parce
que vous voulez vous voulez faire
adopter des projets de loi mais ça prend
la collaboration des gens on l'a vu en
revenant de la pause tout à l'heure le
président est en train de perdre
patience c'est pas facile présentement à
quel point est-ce que vous êtes capable
de travailler dans un environnement
comme celui mais je pense que c'est il
faut noter que c'est difficile et moi
j'étais sur le bord de du président
parce que c'est rendu trop chaude ou
trop chicane
et on a vu tous les matins il y avait
pas de travaux par la main parce que les
consommateurs faisaient quasiment à fait
le batteur au sein de la Chambre de
comédien qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire pour
avoir pour devancer une dizaine de
projets de loi il va falloir prolonger
la séance chaque journée qui nous reste
jusqu'à minuit
il va y avoir des baillons qui vont être
utilisés je présume ah quelle heure côté
absolument mais aussi pour accélérer
notre programme législatif absolument si
on a une telle numéro de journée de
débat il faut il faut que l'ordre le
débat et on va utiliser cette progressif
si on a besoin donc vous avez mis une
dizaine de projets de loi sur la table
voulez-vous tous où il y en a certains
d'entre eux qui sont plus importants
qui sont plus clé que d'autres mais ce
sont en moins 10 projets de loi on veut
tous les passer mais c'est clair que le
projet de loi le projet de loi sur
l'implantation ou l'exécution du budget
très importante
très critique on a aussi un projet de
loi de Sénat pour protéger
l'environnement on a ainsi que vous avez
dit un projet de loi sur les garderies
et aussi le projet c'est 18 pour que les
tech doivent payer leur juste part et
compenser à les maisons de presse pour
leur information qui mettent sur leur
plateforme on a beaucoup entendu parler
cette semaine une rumeur mais on a
beaucoup entendu le mot prorogation ce
serait une bonne idée pour vous de rejet
de recommencer à neuf au mois de
septembre mais vous savez que ça c'était
une décision de quelqu'un qui a toute
une autre salaire et responsabilité de
moi faites partie du gouvernement de
cette personne-là mais quand même un
progression garde sa roule bien on
avance dans un jardin
on va avoir une belle discussion sur des
C 18 on est en train de voir notre
projet qui sont sur le budget donc moi
je pense qu'on n'est pas rendu une
pointe on doit utiliser une telle outil
mais comme j'ai dit c'est c'est la
décision du Premier ministre est-ce que
est-ce que toute la question de la
gérance étrangère et tous les débats que
ça suscité est-ce que ça a fait
dérailler votre programme législatif
regarde c'est toujours dans les mains
des parties d'opposition de choisir leur
sujet pour leur journée vendredi ils ont
décidé de forcer le président de de lire
items dans notre projet de loi sur
l'exécution du budget parce qu'il
voulait pas travailler donc est-ce que
ça nous cause des délais oui est-ce que
c'est fatal notre programme législatif
absolument pas est-ce que Monsieur
Johnson devrait partir mais j'ai
toujours dit que Monsieur Johnson est
une canadien très éminent il était gros
en général président d'université
président d'une faculté de droit écrit
plusieurs livres il a une terrasse une
gouvernement il s'est dit clairement
qu'il veut continuer à son travail donc
moi je suis moi je veux voir c'est quoi
dans ce rapport et sur ce point si
Monsieur polave et Monsieur Blanchette
veut vraiment avoir une caisse une
conversation adulte sur cette question
sont aussi mieux d'aller prendre le
breffage top secret pour voir exactement
les mêmes informations que monsieur John
cenaüs ne pas se faire ce n'est pas être
un chef responsable avez-vous
l'impression d'avoir tourné la page sur
la question de la gérance etc êtes-vous
est-ce
il y a des choses très important notre
comité de parlementaire qui sont
responsables pour le sculté national
continuent à faire leur juste parler
c'est on prend cette question
d'ingérence à être étrangère très au
sérieux on va continuer le faire et
quand moi je fais la porte à porte chez
moi j'entends pas ça j'entends coup de
la vie j'entends qu'est-ce qu'on fait
pour Ukraine j'entends qu'est-ce qu'on
va faire pour croire l'économie c'est
pas la question d'ingérence étrangère
que j'entends sur les portes et
maintenant je vais m'adresser aux
députés
albertinent vous avez une nouvelle
Première ministre en première classe
cette semaine madame suites qui a eu qui
a eu des mots quand même un petit
avertissement à l'endroit de votre
gouvernement à la fin de son discours
quand elle a gagné la semaine dernière
en disant pas vrai qu'on va accepter
c'est c'est toutes les mesures de
carbone neutralité sur l'industrie
pétrolière sur la grille électrique sur
le réseau électrique en albertin vous
vous comprenez quoi du message de Madame
Smith mais je pense que c'est
l'opportunité de vraiment sachant
maintenant qu'on a travaillé ensemble
pour
pour la première ministre des gens pour
nous de vraiment trouver les places où
on peut travailler ensemble moi j'ai
travaillé avec Madame
on Alberta pour rendre notre grid de
l'électricité plus propre on est déjà
cette année devant le cible de 2030 déjà
c'est important dans mon compte même ou
juste à côté de mon côté on a head over
météo ce qui a décidé de l'ancien
programme de capturation utilisation
stockage de carbone pour créer le
premier usine de ciment carbonate en
Amérique du Nord en plus air Prax qui a
décidé de venir avec 1,6 milliards de
dollars des États-Unis pour avoir le
plus grand d'installation des durer
d'hydrogène propre au monde et ça c'est
grâce à nos impôts de nos présidents ça
bénéficie les adaptés ça bénéficie
l'Alberta et donc moi je pense que
malgré les mots qu'on échange parfois on
est là pour travailler garde l'Alberta
va mener les premiers canadiennes d'ici
les prochaines deux trois ans donc c'est
une intellect canadienne qu'on travaille
ensemble pas vous c'est pas tous les
Canadiens qu'il la connaissent bien
madame les alberté la connaissent bien
vous la connaissez bien comment vous la
décririez aux gens qui nous écoutent ce
matin et qui la connaissent peut-être
pas mais dans un un
vide dans le passé j'ai expliqué
monsieur Harper au Québécois par mon
travail pour les affaires de Montréal et
je dirais de Madame Smith elle est très
pragmatique mais il faut que vous avez
bien dit maintenant il doit gérer un
cocus qui est majoritairement rural donc
il va avoir un enjeu là-dedans je pense
que notre tâche comme c'est vraiment de
dire avec les débattins et du
démystifier c'est quoi cette question
peut-être parfois faux entre l'urbain et
le rural mais il va falloir bien écouter
et
s'asseoir à la table en commun mais elle
est pragmatique et elle veut défendre
l'intérêt des albertin comme moi je fais
d'ailleurs de ma perspective et donc il
y a du travail devant nous il va avoir
beaucoup de pain sur la planche merci